salut c'est une seconde aujourd'hui on
va parler de ce smartphone l'iphone 5
light et quelques jours j'ai déjà parlé
d'un smartphone d'asus c'était les us
iphone 5 z excellent très très bon
smartphone j'ai trouvé vraiment bien moi
pour la photo pour la vidéo là
maintenant on va regarder ce n fun 5
lite on va regarder s'il est cool s'il
intéressant asus a vraiment fait le
focus là dessus sur la photo d'ailleurs
ses marques et la we love photo donc on
va tester cette asus iphone 5 like qui
en réalité nos produits d'entrée de
gamme dans la gamme iphone 5 vous avez 2
iphone 5 leipp modèle plus light comme
son nom l'indiqué le iphone 5 et les
iphone 5 z qui est le modèle le plus
haut on va donc regarder 625 light c'est
dur à prononcer un iphone 5 lite on va
regarder donc si ce ze5 light est
intéressant s'il tient ses promesses en
photo on va les voir aussi du côté de la
vidéo du côté de l'audio en faire un
point tous complets on va le mettre à nu
on va bousculer un peu voir s'il est
intéressant et vous allez voir on risque
d'être surpris
on y va
dans la famille asus zenfan 5 je veux le
zenfan 5 light je regarde comment il
souffre a comme ça voilà le iphone 5
lite vous ouvrez vous retrouver le même
petit message we love photos directement
produit qui a l'air en tout cas d'être
vraiment assez cool c'est intéressant
c'est pas un smartphone hyper cher vous
trouvez à 299 euros sur le site des u6
intéresse je vous ai mis des liens dans
la description packaging simple sobre
sympa qu'est ce qu'on a ici les us open
cinq light à l'intérieur de cette petite
boîte vous avez là absolument rien voilà
je m'attendais à voir quelque chose
banon ici votre petit pin pour venir
ouvrir vos tiroirs de cartes sim
on a une paire d'écouteurs des petits
bouchons adaptateur à me reposer sur les
écouteurs le câble micro usb vers usb
est ici votre adaptateur secteur qu'en
est il du smartphone en lui-même plutôt
joli la bête on reste vraiment dans ce
cas choisi asus dans sa gamme d iphone 5
c'est à dire un produit qui élégant un
dos qui est vraiment très jolie vous
avez un dos en verre tu trouves vraiment
joli ça c'est un modèle noir mais pour
moi il a des reflets bleus le capteur
d'empreintes digitales convenir
déverrouiller rapidement votre appareil
le plein de regrets sont les traces de
doigts mais ça les traces de doigts sur
un dos en verre on peut pas y couper
le petit logo asus en bas plutôt élégant
du côté de l'écran vous avez une dalle
ip slcd un écran de 6 pouces avec une
résolution fhd plus de 1160 par 1080
pixels un ratio 18/9 enfin d'écran qui
vous filtre à la lumière bleue et donc
ça c'est plutôt intéressant et vous avez
un écran qui occupe 95 3% de la face
avant par rapport à certains modèles du
marché actuel c'est pas énorme
n'oublions pas qu'on est sur un
smartphone du coup quand même moins 300
euros c'est le modèle light de la gamme
iphone 5
c'est plutôt bien on retrouve à l'avant
ces deux grandes caméra haut parleurs et
flash vous avez un écran avec des bords
arrondis en comment va vous avez une
grande bordure sur le haut une grande
bordure sur le bas un grand standard
vous pouvez insérer deux cartes sim et
une carte micro sd qui va jusqu'à de
dera son côté vous avez un bouton de
volume le bouton pour l'allumer et
l'éteindre sur le dessus le port jack de
l'autre côté votre tiroir de cartes sim
et amba votre connecteur micro usb et
hao parleur mono s'ils vont attirer
l'attention c'est bien noté la 120°
grand-angle parce que vous avez à
l'arrière ici une caméra de 16
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 2.2
et une caméra de 8 mégapixels avec un
grand angle à 120 degrés c'est vraiment
ce que met on avoir agi sur son site
internet c'est à dire
photo pas avoir des photos un peu trop
étriqué avoir des personnes qui sont
vraiment en dehors du champ ou alors un
décor qu'on va pas réellement là pour le
coup des photos à 120 degrés à noter
qu'à la vente vous avez une caméra de 5
mégapixels c'est une sony nex-3 176 avec
une ouverture de f 2.0 mais également un
capteur de 8 mégapixels qui ouvre à 120°
nouveau film et en quel cas urgent des
3840 par 2160 pixels à 30 images par
seconde
vous avez à l'arrière notre focus à
détection de phase vous avez aussi une
stabilisation logiciel c'est pas une
stabilisation optique elle est vraiment
logiciel est à dire que ça va venir
gagner un petit peu dans l'image
pour vous stabiliser tout ça et vous
avez aussi la technologie pixel master
de asus pour vraiment avoir un effet
boké avec un flou d'arrière-plan angles
de vision xxl quatre caméras 120° ans le
disions extra large de caméras vente 20
mégapixels de caméra arrière de 16
mégapixels
attention en réalité c'est une caméra à
vendre 1 mégapixels plus une caméra tu
perds xl et une caméra arrière de 16
mégapixels avec une autre caméra arrière
de 8 mégapixels c'est un petit peu
trompeur vous avez un petit 1 qui vous
renvoie tout en bas c'est indiquer ici
caméra principale 20 + 8 120 degrés et
autres caméras 16 +8 120° faire
attention le jeune femme 5 light et le
smartphone idéal pour tous les amoureux
de la photographie soit en des clichés
qui sortent de l'ordinaire c'est
justement ce qu'on va les voir en
extérieur
[Musique]
né le 14 juillet fête nationale oblige
donc on fait un petit repas on n'a que
des potes c'est un peu bucolique lâché
avec elliot mon fiston qui est en train
de parler aux vaches forcément donc tout
se passe bien c'est plutôt cool là donc
je sens la caméra de celle filles
touchent pas les câbles électriques a
dit est un touche pas les fils tu at
elle trop q tu es folle a formé un peu
savoir comment ça se passe ah oui ça
pique
[Musique]
josef fendt sa classe est plutôt un bon
téléphone ce qui était très très malin
de la part d'asus est de mettre une
caméra grand angle à l'avant et à
l'arrière ils ont compris c'était
vraiment ce qui est bien c'est que les
usages se font beaucoup avec la caméra
celle ci avec la caméra arrière le fait
de mettre un grand-angle c'est plutôt
ingénieux c'est plutôt astucieux ça
permettra à tout le monde de s'y
retrouver
alors effectivement on n'est pas sur les
capteurs le plus dingue du marché on
n'est pas sur les meilleurs appareils
photo néanmoins pour faire des souvenirs
des stèles philippe ortiz et sur les
réseaux sociaux
je suis pas hyper hyper hyper hyper
convaincu trouve que la qualité vidéo
globalement est pas mal mais dès lors
que vous voyez pas ce qui se passe dans
votre capteur principal coup pouvait pas
faire le point que vous n'êtes pas sûr
de ça vous fait mal aveugle vous pouvez
pas vous en remettre à l'autofocus parce
que c'est pas extraordinaire non pas que
les sto focus sont de mauvaise qualité
dessus mais vraiment le temps qu'il fait
pas le point lorsque je bouge la maj
luminosité change les réglages se font
pas terrible terrible
après une fois de plus on est sur un
smartphone qui coûte pas très cher
on ne peut pas globalement lui en
vouloir on va pas avoir la même qualité
que se retaper sur le zinc 25 ou alors
carrément sur les iphone 5 z sur les
iphone 5 z pas si vous avez vu la vidéo
de test mais je trouve vraiment bien là
la vidéo à la faible c'est un peu moyen
est vraiment vous soyez là vous pour
vérifier ce qui se passe directement sur
l'écran en pesant de smartphones en
filmant directement la caméra arrière
sans avoir bretons moniteur pour
vérifier vous risquez vraiment d'être
surpris dans des déconvenues
sinon ce sont les caméras avant ça fait
le job vous avez des vidéos qui sont
corrects sans être exceptionnel je vous
le dis une fois de plus on ne fera
croire que coûte 300 euros
on va pas attendre les performances
extraordinaires en termes de photos et
de vidéos
le rendu des photos et pas mal par kung
fu qui a une vraie vraie différence de
traitement ici par exemple ce sont la
caméra arrière 16 mégapixels j'ai plutôt
mal même rendu une couleur que six
nommés sur la caméra grand angle
si vous regardez la terre en bas la
couleur va pas du tout et il a même son
grand pont au notaire un peu plus main
au nez sur l'autre c'est un peu plus
vers tout ce qui est arbre derrière ça
va pas mal sans la prairie ça pas mal
dès que je passe sur l'autre c'est un
tout petit peu plus chaud pareil les
blancs si vous la regardez sur la caméra
classique les blancs tire un peu vers le
vert sur l'autre on tire un peu plus
d'un rouge
c'est très léger mais il ya quand même
une différence néanmoins rendu haute
qualité ça marche je crache pas dans la
soupe chaude et une fois de plus ou ne
sera pas une coupe pas hyper cher qui
parlent même étalonnage de couleur entre
les deux caméras c'est pas choquant bon
pour mettre 300 balles on n'a pas causé
plaindre on a rendu également de
différence sur la caméra avant vous
soyez sur l'a20 mégapixels sur la 8
mégapixels bon c'est pas non plus hyper
hyper choquant par contre ce qu'on peut
voir tout de suite lorsque vous regardez
ciel ici tout de suite
il est un peu trop exposé pourtant pions
le dr bond il ya forcément quelques
imperfections sur cet appareil sur la
caméra de sel fixe sur les cadets
l'arrière au risque de me répéter on est
sur un smartphone qui est pas hyper cher
on peut pas non plus trop de l'emploi
asus a fait un smartphone qui est plutôt
cohérent je note quand même ces petits
bémols en termes de photos de vidéos la
qualité et par dingo
si vous voulez monter vraiment en
qualité aller sur les iphone 5 ou alors
carrément sur iphone 5 z
[Musique]
en terme de puissance maintenant il
existe deux versions soit une version
avec un qualcomm snapdragon 630 couplé à
4 gigas de ram et 64 giga de stockage
soit un dragon 430 couplé à 3 giga de
ram et 32 gigas de stockage en attendant
sur le site d'asus si vous recherchez
j'ai trouvé que le modèle avec le sabre
un gone 630 l'autonomie n'est pas mal
non plus indépendants une fois de plus
de votre utilisation c'est toujours un
petit peu relative parce que on peut
vous faire des tests en me disant en
autonomie il va durer temps il va durer
tant ça dépend complètement de ce que
vous allez lui demander ça dépend des
jeux ça dépend de vous devrez de jeu ça
dépend de votre durée d'utilisation vous
pouvez durer une journée avec sans aucun
problème sur utilisation classique
si vous êtes très gourmand forcément ça
va diminuer comme neige au soleil mais
dans l'absolu c'est un smartphone qui se
tire plutôt bien sûr une journée sans
aucun problème pour info vous avez une
batterie de trois mille trois cent
millions paire eur il ya aussi du
bluetooth 4.2 du nfc pour avoir un
google paye c'est le paiement
dématérialisé de google il tourne avec
la surcouche z 8,5 sur un android
huit auraient au haut niveau le 2 ça va
il marche pas trop mal vous avez dit
sont là je les pousse à fond vous
écouter côté applications il ya
l'application notamment celles fille
master dans l'application celle-ci
masters ce qui est marrant c'est de vous
rendre beau ou de vous rendre belle vous
avez un beauty level qui va en réalité
venir complètement vous lisser la peau
je ne sais pas si vous voyez
mais j'ai la peau complètement lisse et
regarder en dessous de mes yeux là je
passe up sur ce modèle là j'ai tout de
suite une peau un peu moins lisse et un
peu plus de rythme sur la tronche je
passe là ça me lisent tous alors
forcément c'est très flatteur
c'est très joli mais ça c'est loin de la
réalité c'est l'fun 5 light si vous fait
de l'oeil à qui est il destiné
alors le tout premier point que je vois
en toi est extrêmement positif sur ce
produit c'est design vous avez ce dos en
verre avec cet effet de relief qui est
très sympa qui est très jolie il prend
effectivement des traces de doigts on va
pas se mentir là dessus il ya quelques
marques et qui sont dessus forcément
comme tous les smartphones avec les dos
en verre il faut passer un petit coup de
chiffon vous chantez contrat votre
t-shirt vous nettoyez comme ça non vous
n'avez pas de problème l'écran est
plutôt bien en termes de performances il
peut vous convenir dès lors vous faites
des jeux de temps en temps des choses
pas trop gourmand
on ne vous fait pas tourner trop
d'applications en même temps pour
l'utilisation un peu classique mail
internet vidéo
franchement il fera très très très bien
la faire maintenant côté selphy photo je
suis un petit peu mitigé je trouve qu'il
est pas mal
il a un rendu qui est correct alors une
fois de plus et c'est souvent un petit
peu le piège avec ses smartphones là
c'est quand on est habitués ici beaucoup
de smartphones on devient plus en plus
exigeants néanmoins il faut savoir
raison garder comme on dit
et puis quand on fait des tests de
smartphones c'est savoir remettre le
smartphone dans sa catégorie
là on est sur un smartphone d'entrée de
gamme à moins de 300 euros alors on
n'est pas dans l'ultra d'entrée de gamme
se passe à gaza comme ça on est passés
les smartphones à moins de 100 euros
on est sur un smartphone à moins de 300
euros qui a forcément plus d'exigences
qu'un smartphone à moins de 200 euros
néanmoins on va pas avoir des exigences
comme un smartphone moyen de gamme sont
tournés 400 500 euros cependant que dans
sa catégorie il a quand même certains
atouts non négligeables
le fait de pouvoir avoir un grand-angle
c'est vraiment appréciable
on va lui reprocher l'exposition qui est
pas forcément optimale en termes de
luminosité
des fois il va avoir un petit peu de mal
à faire le point lorsque je fais des
photos et ça c'est un peu ce que j'ai
regretté sur les cannes et l'arrière
prouver - faire le bon point même si
avec le doigt j'appuie jeudi c'est la
fin point faire le point il galère un
petit peu c'est pas là où il va être le
meilleur
là où il sera le meilleur c'est pas pour
choper un bout de détail choper une
fleur son p quelque chose qui se détache
un petit peu c'est vraiment ton prendre
en photo un ensemble là par contre il
sentira parfaitement bien et l'exercice
il le maîtrisera donc attention à ce que
vous allez faire avec ce smartphone
quels sont vos besoins réels qu'est ce
que vous allez faire avec
je vous dis j'ai passé du temps essayer
de choper la bonne fleurs avoir la bonne
photo
l'abeille dessus situe au bon endroit il
a fallu apprendre à quelques fois pour
finir par avoir un cliché qui est quand
même pas mal
donc au final est ce que faisait 25 live
vous pouvez vous positionner dessus j'ai
tendance à dire oui si vous aimez asus
si vous aimez le look si le dos en verre
vous plaît si vous êtes adepte de
cellfish surtout si votre utilisation
correspond à ce que je vais vous décrire
si c'est pas le cas je vous conseille de
passer soit aux iphone 5 soit aux iphone
5 z soit si vous verrez dans un
smartphone à moins de 300 euros d'aller
voir la concurrence ce qui se passe
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous l'avez déjà vu des
smartphones de chez asus si c'est le cas
est-ce qui vous ont plu 6 et paca est ce
que vous pourriez vous laisser tenter
comment est ce que vous le trouvez déjà
d'après juste éthique comment trouver le
look est ce que vous trouvez jeu
est-ce qu'il vous surprend est ce que
vous aimez les produits d'asus en 2018
marquez va de son commentaire est dit
est ce que cet iphone 5 lite vous fait
de l'oeil
est ce que vous avez acheté les iphone
ça claque le iphone 5 ou alors carrément
le z35 zen vous marquez tout sans
commentaire quant à nous on reste
connectés parce que plein d'autres trucs
qui arrive il va y avoir plein de
nouveautés plein de tests plein de
choses des surprises des voyages faire
plein de trucs donc on reste connectés
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
je vous dis à très bientôt paraît tout
simple si vous avez d'autres questions
suggestions pourrait bien déposer
directement et si vous voulez me joindre
également sur twitter ayant parlé @
monsieur gros soyez ça je vous dis à
très bien d'autres prenez soin de vous
[Musique]